je reçois maintenant andré dussollier
pour son rôle dans les enfants du marais
le dernier long métrage de jean becker
attendu sur nos écrans mercredi prochain
dans la france de l'après grande guerre
une chronique bucolique qui filme des
amitiés viriles et rurales ou un
dussollier dandy et mondain vient
promener sa précieuse et chaleureuse
nonchalance bonsoir andré dussollier
donc les enfants du marais film de jean
becker adaptation et dialogues du fameux
sébastien japrisot alors on va le site
et les autres acteurs passés comme une
pléiade d'acteurs il ya jacques gamblin
ya jacques villeret que vous avez connu
au conservatoire michel serrault
isabelle carré même eric cantona qui se
sort plutôt plutôt bien très bien son
rôle
alors c'est un film assez étrange parce
que c'est un film je dirais un peu
intemporel à une époque où on y appuyait
toujours deux trois homosexuels par film
ou alors il ya des extra terrestres là
il n'y a pas d'homosexuels n'ya pas
d'extraterrestres la lèvre et spéciale à
d'effets spéciaux etc
la masse du muguet au début du film
c'est quand même en effet très inattendu
mais quand on a mis le pied il me semble
qu'en dedans quand on voit le film
j'avais pas vu le film tout entier avec
mécènes pour cause je sais pas on se
laisse prendre par une émotion ça
raconte en effet l'amitié de gens qui
sont assez démunis qui n'ont pas
beaucoup de moyens et c'est vrai que
c'est une grande opposition avec ce
qu'on vit aujourd'hui avec on peut voir
au cinéma est ce qu'on vit c'est à dire
qu'on est un peu dans les villes dans
des cités un peu robotisée et c est là
au contraire c'est vous parlez de
cruseilles tout à l'heure c'est un peu
ça me rappelle ce à quoi la campagne il
faut dire en gros se raconter toute
l'histoire enfin il ya deux personnages
qui sont gamblin et vivrait qui vivent
dans un marais près à une grande ville
enfin près du prêt d'une ville de
province
et puis bon bah gamblin il supporte un
peuvent y est quand même un vrai bon à
rien dans cette ville il ya un
personnage que vous incarnez alors là
avec une drôlerie formidable dhibou dit
toujours qu'on vous donne jamais de à
ces deux rôles de composition rigal
personnage d'amédée c'est quand même un
rôle de composition
c'est ce qui m'a tenté un rôle de
composition c'est un type maniéré un peu
célibataire un peu court en ce moment
maire du mans et qui est très très loin
et de villerest de camblain qui se
débrouille pour vivre avec la réalité et
l'huile est plutôt dans le deuil de
leurs bras des travaux un champ ou à des
choses comme ça et vous en faites vous
voulez être copain avec eux parce que
vous vous les admirer un petit peu parce
qu'ils sont libres oui je fais partie
d'un milieu bourgeois qui est un peu
démuni aussi qu'il ya pas beaucoup de
moyens et donc il ya quelque chose qui
nous réunit tous éteints c'est l'amitié
la fraternité surtout la possibilité de
participer à des choses et marielle
auquel je dont j'étais un peu détaché
mais quelque chose qui se dégage de de
leur personnalité celle ci c'est ça qui
est intéressant il me semble dans le
film il ya aussi michel serrault mais
aussi qui a lui était dans les marais à
lui la fortune amassée à la ferraille et
puis après mais tous ces personnages
sont dans des situations un petit peu
précaire enfin sauf michel serrault mais
enfin détroit dont on parle là et ils
sont obligés de se débrouiller par
eux-mêmes voient avec c'est comme si
aujourd'hui on a le progrès a fait qu'on
a beaucoup de moyens et qu'on oublie un
petit peu l'effort personnel alors là
les forfaits que toutes les choses ont
de la valeur et lui c'est aussi la
solidarité entre les gens dont nous
parle toute la journée de solidarité à
la télévision là on voit bien la vraie
solidarité enfin gamblin on voit bien
qu'il est venu là après la guerre de 14
il reste là dans ce marais uniquement
parce qu'il voit bien que s'ils s'en
aller villeray et sa famille crèveront
de faim
donc il ya une vraie solidarité qui réel
paquet qui est proche des gens c'est pas
des grandes phrases la télé etc c'est
filmé de façon extrêmement simple parce
que les scènes se sont révélés comme ça
les unes après les autres il ya une
émotion qui finit par se dégager
semble-t-il par dans cette histoire qui
est tout à fait en effet comme vous
l'avez dit tracy n'est attendu
aujourd'hui
comme si c'était un compte rendu de ce
qui était avancé patine nostalgique -
c'est pour dire qu'en cette fin de
siècle voilà comment s'opère la présence
était dans les années ben oui alors on
disait vous étiez donc de cruseilles à
fils unique vos parents travaillent et
aux impôts au trésor public comme elle
dit alors vous avez découvert le théâtre
avec un prof de français qui un jour
vous à vous montrer poil de carotte
vous avez vu sur scène poil de carotte
et vous avez été fasciné de voir que des
gens pouvait rire et pleurer sur scène
et que finalement il y en a qui paient
pour venir voir ça c'est une révélation
pourrait dire
la science et surtout que tout d'un coup
je voyais des gens en effet laissé libre
cours à leurs états d'âme à leur
sentiment qu'ils étaient les acteurs et
ça me donnait tout d'un coup une
ouverture par rapport à la vie ou plutôt
les choses étaient contre et on est pas
on peut pas toujours dire ce qu'on veut
dire ce qu'on pense faire ce qu'on
ressent et là tout d'un coup le métier
d'acteur m'ouvrait des horizons que
elle vivait dans l'ambiance un petit peu
pas confiné mais enfin c'est mon ancien
official s'unissent à l'origine d'un
petit oui les relations village la ville
est restée la première pièce de théâtre
le premier film c'est les 400 coups vous
avez les 400 coups c'était une belle
fille comme moi de truffes alors ça
c'est là dessus que vous avez fait
messieurs vous avez vu c'est que j'ai
400 et nous aviez 12 13 ans non mais pas
confiance fait d'ailleurs on vous avait
laissé le voir parce qu'il avait eu le
prix de l'office catholique
oui bon alors vos parents vous voulez
faire ça voulait faire acteur puis vos
parents vous dise comme comme à beaucoup
d'enfants passe ton bac parce qu'un bac
d'abord et alors là vous êtes vachement
sérieux parce que vous allez à grenoble
et qu'est ce que vous faites comme et
dessus de ses études de linguistique et
de lettres modernes et je vais même
jusqu'au bout et au bout on me dit bon
d'accord la maintenant vous pouvez être
assistante philologie à la fac d'oranger
dit non merci et longue
non je ne suis jamais allé et puis
j'avais pas du tout envie de d'enseigner
la philologie je me sentais aucune
aptitude pour ça mais j'avais été au
goût de ses études j'aimais bien la
littérature mais j'avais toujours
parallèlement fait du théâtre est alors
en 69
c'est à nous de paris à vous débarquez à
paris les 23 ans et là c'est de sauter
le pas se leurrer venant d'une famille
de fonctionnaires
vous devenez un saltimbanque prix parce
que ça fait un peu peur vu de la
province comme ça on sait pas quel est
ce milieu et cetera est bon
alors je me suis en effet fait j'ai fait
mes études et je me suis payé la liberté
avec ses diplômes l'a peut-être de faire
enfin ce que j'avais envie de faire du
théâtre
et donc j'ai débarqué à paris je mettais
un petit peu renseigné j'ai fait un
cursus normal quand je célèbre aux
prairies money c'est un cours privé est
à c'est un monsieur qui s'appelle jean
périmony à qui je dois beaucoup et qui
est un processus et la cua j'ai commencé
là j'ai la figuration un peu dans les
faits dim dam dom avec jugnot et après
vous rentrez leur a pris pour entrer au
conservatoire alors là vous rencontrez
vivrait donc c'est quand même marrant
c'est marrant quand même parce que tout
le monde est passé par là moi je m'en
rends compte en faisant ce boulot il y
avait villeray il y avait berry la mère
nathalie baye est alors dans la classe
au dessus il y avait eu ce ter et webber
est dans la classe au dessous il y avait
giraudeau donc fait malgré tout se
retrouver là alors si vous faites votre
premier film pendant que vous êtes au
conservatoire oui c'était avec françois
truffaut qui était venu voir un
spectacle monté par speisser qui
s'appelait léon 017 nerfs et alors bon
j'ai eu la chance d'être engagé par lui
mais dans un rôle un peu particulier
déjà une composition parce que c'était
l'époque où triomphait les deux styles
hoffman et oui il convoyait se
métamorphoser d'un rose a voulu
absolument faire des rôles de
composition amusé c'est ça qui m'amusait
puis je me disais bien alors après non
ça m'a coincé un peu cette image parce
que on n'a pas vu c'est la première
image qui va reparler de votre image
justement c'est à dire qu'effectivement
là vous avez aussi les coincer vous avez
des lunettes
rivenet des gants jaunes introverti un
peu maladroit et à la bi je me faisais
manipulé par planet la frank était en
prison bref
et ça m'a poursuivi un peu ma poche
grâce à nina companeez à la télévision
qui m'avait vu au conservatoire passer
des comédies puis ensuite grâce à deux
louches aussi après j'ai retrouvé un
rôle plus proche de moins ce qu'il faut
dire que vous avez le premier prix du
conservatoire en comédie classique
comédie moderne étrangères comme comme
huster non comme perrin on a faim on a
passé deux camps militaires de l'année
la même et uster aussi parler d'avantagé
d'avant vous avez plutôt l'image ne se
passait pas du tout reproche loin de là
à vous est plutôt l'image d'un gentleman
acteurs on dirait vous êtes plutôt
proche de cary grant ou de james stewart
que de de niro de pacino ou ces mecs là
quoi oui peut-être
on peut me donner ce style de rôle et ça
me fait plaisir j'aime bien james
stewart mais mais en même temps c'est
plus tellement ce cinéma là qu'on fait
en vous et en france qui est pas
tellement majoritaire il semble à ce
genre de comédie là on ne peut pas dire
si ça se retrouve ailleurs chez d'autres
cinéastes mais pas tellement en france
et donc mais en même temps mon désir ça
n'a pas été de rester uniquement dans
une enveloppe ou dans un style ou dans
une image c'était plutôt de me balader
on est quand même dans une époque vous
rêvez d'extravagance vous rêvez deux
frères dont césar de oui le blason dans
ruy blas vous rêvez de shakespeare
cirque en fait vous avez le sentiment
cela vous avez quel âge 52 3 en 53
ça a besoin comme tant de bien de vous
exprimer c'est peut-être mon équipe qui
compte c'est celle en vie la fois et
peut-être la crédibilité à travers la
personne si vous êtes très français un
peu un peu provincial qua non sans doute
bas je ne renie pas mais enfin les rôles
sont fait pour qu'on se dépayser qu'on
ait des apparences reddition croyez pas
que c'est le poids de votre éducation ça
c'est à dire que finalement on n'échappe
pas son éducation les shops bars échappe
pas mais on est acteur justement pour y
échapper et moi ça me gêne pas de me
grimer où ça me gêne pas de même sans
brimer de jouer des choses qui sont à
l'opposé de moi si j'ai choisi ce métier
c'est justement pour ça pouvoir me
libérer et faire des choses tout à fait
une attention gérez vous-mêmes et oui
mais dans amédée vous le faites quoi je
lui aurais je ferai dans deux films et
ça dépend si les films sont vus beaucoup
pas mais je le fais de plus en plus peut
être lâche qui me le permet vous
travaillez beaucoup truffaut disais il
est comme comme bouquet comme michel
bouquet il répète csn après alors c'est
quoi ce thème quand vous allez savoir
tourner oui c'est ça savez vous trouvez
c'est insensé
évidemment je dis et répète avant et je
les joue mais enfin il ya une telle
frustration au cinéma parce qu il
évoquant ses fruits s'est renseigné on
passa pas comme le théâtre
donc évidemment j'avais tendance à les
répéter après mais c'était de prendre ma
première expérience graphique donc après
je sais ce que j'ai bien fait ce que je
viens vous leur fusil à réaliser dans un
coin du plateau machette a vécu un truc
il emmène les propos pour conclure il ya
une bonne définition de vous qui a été
donné par quelqu'un qu'on aime tous
beaucoup sigean enfin qu'on aimait
malheureux est plus là que jean louis
borie critique du nouvel obs qui disait
dussollier c'est un belmondo qui aurait
lu mais enfin écoutez moi je lis
l'équipe attendait pas dire globalement
de ne jamais me voilà non j'ai lu
beaucoup à une certaine période mais
enfin je dis si je dis encore mais
peut-être moins je sais pas c'est
classement on peut en faire plein on
peut faire d'autre on entend tellement
d'autres villes oasis
voilà donc jorat merci en tous les cas
des corrections de ne rien rater de
l'inaptitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux